what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are picking up with Justice
League dark which is actually kind of
cool it's a quick little three issue
story 2k off the whole thing so the way
that these stories always played out
that Justice League dark line of comics
is this is where you found like what
what little crossover existed between
like the magical side of DC and the
superhero data side of DC this is where
you found it and that's one of the big
differences between like DC Comics and
Marvel Comics with Marvel Comics there
really is no differentiation between the
magical side and the non magical side
and really the biggest reason for that
is because the magic used by various
people in Marvel Comics that power is
usually used in conjunction with
superhero antics so like Doctor Strange
will use like levitation or he'll use
like tell everything or telekinesis or
something like that
during a particular file cast some kind
of spell or something like that on the
DC side things are totally different you
have like the basically the whole
magical side and that's a whole other
side of DC the only person that really
crosses over really the only only three
people that really cross over would be
like Zatanna Constantine and Swamp Thing
and that's really about it but Justice
League dark is really the attempt by DC
and has been for the times they've done
it before to kind of bridge that gap and
to create a Justice League line of
comics it takes the magical side and
blends it over with a superhero side the
issue is that I don't think DC has
really found like the winning recipe in
order to make that happen but this is
the first time James tin Ian's writing
this and James tin Ian's one hell of a
writer so I'm really curious to see how
he manages to pull this off but what we
do here is we initially pick up with
Zatara herself now those you guys who
were unfamiliar with her character
katana of course is the daughter of
Zatara and zatara's has long since been
out of the picture in DC but she is a
magician of sorts or a person who deals
in like you know witchcraft sorcery
what-have-you but always has to sell
assayer spells backwards in order to use
them which makes her pretty unique and
so initially what she does is kind of
going this little bit of an explanation
here and say like in the world of you
know in the world that we live in
there's a magical side that very few
people know about and that when people
go to see a magic show what they think
is what they believe they're seeing is
illusion when in reality they're seeing
actual magic and it's kind of a funny
thing because what cetana says is that
her job isn't really to be a magician
her job is to lie to the eyes of the
people who are watching it to basically
create her spells in such a way to where
they look like illusion but she talks
about how this whole thing unfolds and
that because the magical side is so
unpredictable and because it's so
powerful if they're not careful it'll
run awry and that's exactly what happens
Tana basically loses control of her
magic in a response Wonderwoman
seemingly appears out of nowhere and
begins trying to destroy this monster
alongside cetana now it's kind of a
crazy thing because when zoton it goes
to cast her spells the monster shoots a
back at her it basically channels her
abilities right back at her again and so
that's when things get a little hairy
here because then the question becomes
what in the world is going on here like
how is it that one of the most powerful
magic wielders in all of DC is losing
her control of magic but this monster is
dealt with quick fast and in a hurry
this is really more of James Tinian kind
of you know giving us a taste and simply
saying like magic is beginning to run
awry and so at this point we pick up
with kind of a gathering of these
various magical beings John Constantine
Oz is hot or herself and that's usually
what happens here where you have like
some major earth-shattering event that
will bring together the Justice League
whenever you have something that
challenges the magical realm it brings
together magic gatherers so you have
like Etrigan and you have Jason blood
and you have like all these various
people which boy and and so on and so
forth but for Wonder Woman she's not
really part of this realm and that's
kind of the funny thing about her
character Wonder Woman's never really
displayed overt magic magical use right
she's never liked cast a spell to give
herself telepathy or anything like that
she's tied into the Amazonians witch in
them you know in and of themselves are
tied somewhat into magic but she's not
on the same level as like Constantine at
least that never really seemed to be the
case and so where she ends up going to
what's basically the this you know the
bar out in the middle of nowhere in
order to you know see if anybody's there
that she can you know seek for aid
everybody's basically gone now of course
this is given to us in a couple
different forms the first comes through
Detective champ who basically says no
one really comes here anymore nobody
goes to the oblivion bar anymore it's
just really considered to be a place
it's not safe because the Dark Knight's
metal they knew about it which means
that it's only a matter of time before
everybody else does and so we have to
find another safe haven but the other
part of this is that they've all been
called off for something that's one of
the reasons why you see virtually nobody
here and so we're wonderful and
basically takes detective chimp and they
start going around and investigating and
seeing what's going on we switch over to
Jason blood now Jason blood being here
is really kind of cool cuz you've got
like Deadman and you've got a lot of a
lot of the characters that you know from
the magical realm who were all here and
Jason blood basically says look it's
only a matter of time before we have to
do something you know and of course he's
not really speaking on behalf of a
chicken so much as he's just kind of
speaking with regards to everything
that's going on here
and he says like look someone somewhere
is taking away our ability to control
magic and with that being the case we
have to act here now this is something I
want you guys to notice because I was
100% sure how to make of this but there
is a guy all the way in the back corner
who looks like the Phantom Stranger and
I'm not sure if that's actually him or
not but if it is as far as I'm aware it
marks the first time we've seen him in
all of like the new 52 and DC Weaver but
while that's going on so Tana is just
kind of standing in the corner listen to
everything unfold and while that's
happening she's met by like an ayah on a
plant which is kind of funny because of
course then in turn she realizes it's
basically Swamp Thing watching
everything unfold now at this point we
switch over to man-bat now of course
man-bats been brought in by Wonder Woman
really is like a last resort because man
that's not tied into into magic
different things like that but that's
where where the the role of Justice
League dark kind of begins to manifest
and begins to change but at the same
time adapt a lot of like the old
standards that we used to have where the
Justice League dark focuses largely on
like magic and things along those lines
invoking man-bat allows James tinning to
bring in characters that are otherwise
outcast they kind of turn Justice League
dark into the new version of Justice
League International post-crisis where
it's basically a book of the unsalables
you would never really see a solo series
for man-bat you would never really see a
solo series for detective chimp because
they're really not interesting enough to
hold one I mean a miniseries definitely
but certainly not an ongoing and so with
this whole thing happening the way that
it is what they've been doing is
basically rounding up corpses or at
least uh man bats been rounding up
courses that belong to people that
seemingly have been controlled or ruined
or or in some form or fashion affected
by this kind of dark magic that's outta
this dark energy that's essentially
overtaking the various magic wielders
ability to control magic itself now
picking up with us Itano
once she meets with with Swamp Thing is
actually kind of funny because she shows
up here and she's like so like let me
understand its the whole world to go
into pot everything is going to pieces
the people are losing control of magic
some dark energy is seizing control of
everything and you're sitting here
staring at trees like Swamp Thing is the
ultimate hippie right he's like the
ultimate millennial like the world's
going to pieces and all he cares about
is planting trees and it's just kinda
like okay like I guess I understand your
swamp things coming from it's still a
little strange to me but what isn't
happening is he says look I've kind of
been communing with this tree because
it's not part of the green it's not part
of nature on earth and so the result is
that it wants to speak directly to you
and when it does it starts talking to
his Etana and actually taking on the
form of her father to a degree and
basically saying like they are coming
everything is coming for you now this is
kind of an interesting scenario because
what James Kenyon does here is he toys
with the idea
her father's still alive in some form or
fashion now we're gonna get the you know
touched on that a little bit more here
in a second of course I feel like this
is gonna be an ongoing theme so I don't
want to delve too deep into it on the
off chance that we end up spoiling
something inadvertently but the idea is
that they are coming these beings are
coming for you guys and they're going to
kill you all and so it was kind of crazy
because what is up happening is
switching back over directly to Wonder
Woman and Detective champion man-bat is
that when this being is talking to his
Etana and when it tries to consume her
suddenly all these corpses start
activating and when they do of course
everybody leaps in and then he has a
Tana and Swan thing who show up and
really just kind of turns into a quick
little skirmish where they're taking out
these corpses that are trying to kill
people what this does is this picks up
with a group traveling to visit dr. dr.
fate almost at Doctor Strange the reason
why they they go to visit dr. fate is
because within the DC universe dr. fate
is like like the top sorcerer like there
are people beyond dr. fate for example
like Nabu the person they're really
going to see besides dr. fate and the
person they gave dr. fate his powers now
Nabu is part of a group called the Lords
of order and in DC Comics the Lords of
order and the Lords of chaos are akin to
like master order in Lord chaos and
Marvel except where master order and
more chaos really looked like the cosmos
and say like all life itself has to
exist within order in chaos the Lords of
order and the Lords of chaos largely
seem to be isolated to like magic to
make sure that like magic doesn't go
awry in any one particular direction and
when they go to visit him they basically
say look we need to talk to Navi like we
need to talk to this guy and figure out
what in the world is going on with magic
because he's like the one person to ask
there and so the result is that what
happens is dr. fate tells a story of
sorts and says that like in the early
days of Earth there were beings who were
trying to create a better world more or
less and in doing so they started
tapping into magic and when they did it
allowed for like a wide array of
different things to happen from for them
to try to make the world a better place
which really kind of offers an origin on
where magic comes from on the planet
Earth within the realm of DC now again
people like Nabu he comes from a
different a whole different planet he
comes from sylia or something along
those lines and supposedly they're the
first sentient races but the Green
Lantern mythos would tell you otherwise
with the guardians of the universe but
regardless of the scenario when Nabu
actually begins to address everything
that's going on like when he actually
makes his debut he basically tells Diana
Prince tells Wonder Woman you're not
part of this world there's no reason for
you to be here not only that you guys
are meddling with things you can't begin
to understand magic will end just like
everything else and the other
are basically coming here and they're
the ones that are going to kill at all
that's the way it is as it was almost
kind of bleak and it's almost a little
hopeless here now something else that
gets hit on is that really before Naboo
that popped up dr. fate had gone as far
as to say is that that the Tana had kind
of betrayed their group in order to go
visit and really take up allegiance with
Wonder Woman and so again it really hits
the nail on the head of this idea that
the magical community is very much
isolated and self-contained and it's one
of these things worse like you stay away
we stay away and that's really kind of
how their whole scenario unfolds and so
what happens is the first of the other
kind begins to arrive and then of course
ends up kind of wreaking havoc on the
various characters who were there and in
attacking everybody that's arriving
there now this is important because when
it arrives it starts talking to
everybody and it reveals some very very
important things where the various
members of Justice League dark face-off
against it and try to destroy it they're
basically helpless the thing keeps like
healing itself it's basically made of
pure magic but it keeps saying things
like we're going to take back what's
stolen and that's what we kind of get
the other side of the equation basically
saying that like the magic that was
wielded in the early days when the first
book of spells was made was essentially
stolen magic it was magic that didn't
really belong to the people who took it
they just took it and then started using
it and so like anything else that's
taken there have to be consequences for
this at some point later on down the
line and that's how this works there are
consequences for this particular thing
and the other kind are the ones who were
coming here to take it now for the most
part everyone falls in the face of this
guy and and the power is the power that
he wields is something akin to like
reality manipulation mind-bending he
melts detective chimp you have swamp
team that goes to try to grab him he
basically just like burns his hand to
pieces literally converts it like like
turns into to dust almost or you know
burns him away it takes John Constantine
trying to like channeling all this
magical energy unto himself was
technically he shouldn't be able to do
it would destroy his physical form of he
tried that's one of the reasons why
people like Jason blood are host for
beings like Etrigan is because when it
comes to using that extreme level of
demonic power gone gone the form of man
arise a demon Etrigan Jason blood will
disappear and etch organ will take its
place
a net Rogan's form can easily handle all
that magic because the guys are walking
talking demon so again it's kind of
interesting here but what is up
happening is that as this you know other
kind this first the other con goes
through and starts examining everybody
he examines Wonder Woman and his
response is there's something strange
about you there's a magical power in you
that I don't recognize as it was really
like it's really James tinny ins way of
saying actually Wonder Woman is magical
she does have magical
and kind of taps into these and wakes
them up for a moment and when he does
that like she immediately lets off like
this blinding mass of energy
now James Tinian keeps us very ambiguous
intentionally he doesn't tell us what
kind of power
Wonder Woman's wielding all he says is
that it was enough to basically burn
this other kind and send it fleeing back
to its own dimension but what is also
done here is is piqued the interest of
the other kind and that means it like
now they all sort they're all gonna
start looking at Wonder Woman to see
what kind of power she possesses but
it's cool because going forward it looks
like it'll be a major plot point what's
her magical ability what can she do is
she channeling the power of Zeus is it
like a whole nother element of magic
that we don't know anything about it's
left on ambiguity but it's good because
it keeps you interested to see what it
is it happens next
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here - comments explained to
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the rock or if you
guys enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like and I will catch you all later
[Music]
[Music]